in singapore preparations are underway
as the asia pacific's key security
summit returns to the city-state after a
two-year hiatus due to covet-19
restrictions
it will provide a face-to-face encounter
between senior u.s and chinese defense
officials amid growing tensions
the summit is named for the hotel
hosting the event and is organized by
the london-based international institute
for strategic studies or the double iws
the main topic of the shangri-la
dialogue is the u.s and china relations
between the two superpowers are bad and
getting worse and so the two defense
ministers from the country will both be
speaking
now in its 19th year the meetings have
become a key forum for debating the
region's security challenges
the conference has traditionally
attracted attention not just for the
speeches and more public aspects but for
the bilateral and multilateral meetings
that take place quietly on the sidelines
until now the u.s and chinese defense
chiefs have only spoken on the phone
one of the big uh
talking points of this week is whether
lloyd austin the u.s defense secretary
and general wayfong her the chinese
defense secretary are actually going to
meet each other for the very first time
and so those meetings are important
they're the way that business gets done
in international defense diplomacy
washington has repeatedly stressed the
importance of the indo-pacific and
accused beijing of aggressive actions in
the region particularly over the south
china sea and taiwan
beijing has also criticized the u.s for
playing what it calls geopolitical games
with the region over issues such as a
security pact between australia the uk
and the us known as orcas which will
help australia to acquire
nuclear-powered submarines i think for
the first time indonesia analysts say
middle powers in the region are hoping
tensions can be resolved
we need to ask whether or not
competition could be de-escalated is it
managed or is it going to be one and i
think these are the questions that are
still not being fully answered but i
think from the perspective of southeast
asian states at least in an ideal world
we would like to see the us china
competition not only peacefully managed
but hopefully de-escalated and resolved
regional issues such as the violence in
myanmar with hundreds of civilians
killed since the 2021 coup will also be
discussed but with no representatives of
the junta or the lawmakers in exile
invited
organizers hope for a productive weekend
that leads to solutions rather than
further tensions jessica washington al
jazeera singapore